what is that
that dead body Daphne found floating in
the water was finally revealed in the
White Lotus season 2 finale I just knew
I was going to want to see the finale
and Creator Mike whites explaining his
decision to kill off a main character I
just think
dying at the hands of someone else felt
too tragic major spoiler ahead if you
haven't watched in three
two
one
so in the end the dead body belonged to
Jennifer coolidge's beloved character
Tanya
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so what exactly happened to Tanya oh my
God turns out Tanya's new friends were
revealed to be in a long con involving
an attempt to kill her and take all her
money which her husband Greg was a part
of but she ended up killing the men
while aboard their yacht on the way back
to the hotel from Palermo
no it's all right I'm alive
yeah not exactly just when fans thought
Tanya got away she suffers an accident
as she tries to escape you've got this
[Music]
as for why Mike White decided to kill
her off well it had to do with the
statement she made in season one Tanya
is sitting with Craig in the last
episode and he's talking about his
health issues and she says I've had
every kind of treatment over the years
death is the last immersive experience I
haven't tried and I was thinking it'd be
so fun to bring Tanya back because she's
such a great character but maybe that's
the journey for her as like a journey to
death
but Mike knew he had to send the season
one fave off in the best way possible
they love her as a character and
obviously loved Jennifer but it just
felt like you know we're going to Italy
she's such a kind of Diva Larger than
Life female archetype it just felt like
we could devise our own operatic
conclusion to Tanya's life and her story
so it just made me laugh to think like
she would like take out all of these
cabal of killers and that after she
successfully does that then she just
dies this Derpy death and it just felt
like that's just so Tanya everybody has
been gushing about you Jennifer
um they look up to you how does that
make you feel well it's probably because
I'm the oldest
no because you're a legend that's why
you're a legend you're a legend icon
well we won't see Tanya at another White
Lotus Resort Again Jennifer isn't
leaving the franchise empty-handed the
actress won an Emmy for her first
go-around as Tanya in season one your
Emmy all these famous fans like Prince
Harry and Meghan Markle does that fill
you with pride or pressure
well it's over I mean there's nothing I
can do that you know it's maybe we were
filming right now I don't know it would
be different but you film it and you
have to sort of Let It Go and more good
news Jennifer also scored a Golden Globe
nom for her work on season two Jennifer
Coolidge Renaissance should be taught as
an important part of American History I
agree
[Music]